[Music]
great it's impossible not to love Prince
Harry and all his charms and we're
bringing you his 9 absolute cutest
moments from childhood until now
starting with Harry's first day of
nursery school in September 1987 the
three year old was escorted by mom
Princess Diana dad Prince Charles and
big brother Prince William making for an
adorable photo op but it's his little
wave to the press we just can't get
enough up and speaking him showing off
for the cameras at number eight one of
the princes most iconic childhood
moments when it comes to dealing with
the press Prince Harry has a style all
of his own Harry's stuck out his tongue
not once but twice while arriving at
school for a nativity play he played an
adorable pixie by the way Diana quickly
squashed the childish move and tried
hard not to laugh but kids will be kids
at number 7 a bashful 13 year old Prince
meaningless Spice Girls before their
concert in South Africa between the
girls gushing over him and Victoria
Beckham's squeezing his hand there's no
doubt this was the day all of Harry's
teenage dreams came true and from
watching the show to being front and
center at number 6 Harry doing his best
to follow the moves of children at the
Centre for the Deaf in Lesotho back in
2013 he was also summoned to dance
during a visit to the rise life charity
project in Jamaica the year prior we see
you Harry at number 5 Harry and well
embracing their inner kid during a 2016
Star Wars set visit the playful day came
complete with toy guns a lightsaber duel
and even Chewbacca Harry introducing
wife Megan Markel she was late
Australian superfan Daphne done coming
in at number 4 Harry and done go way
back I think felices mutters the sign
and after meeting Megan in 2018 the
Aussie exclaimed she's just what the
Prince needs our number 3 moment is
definitely something we need more of
[Music]
[Applause]
Prince Harry making friends with a
toddler at the 2017 Invictus games after
he Connors sneaking fights of his
popcorn is everything and as if that
weren't cute enough that face we can't
and at number two Harry and Megan's
jeans bond s departure for their evening
wedding reception those smiles the suave
exchange of hands so he could open the
door for his Duchess and the wave as the
newlyweds drove off into the sunset
totally has a swooning but our number
one Harry moment of all time I'm very
excited to announce that baby boy this
morning Harry announcing the birth of
his firstborn child can't help but make
you smile it's been the most amazing
experience I can ever possibly imagine
how any woman does what they do is
beyond comprehension but the only thing
even cuter was watching Harry cradle
Archie as he and Megan introduced him to
the world
[Music]